video-time go I purposefully try to
avoid dating East African stuff I will
admit that you avoid avoid at all costs
that's good they look like you're wrong
you know what attacks it goes so incest
you right away
I want my mom to disapprove of who I'm
babe it's super important good lot mom's
like lover god bless sir don't say mom
looks like you don't want to this older
people just said I see low-key racist
[ __ ] you I believe your mom it like this
horn you like yes that's how I know
she's the one
so all this to say I want my mom to
disapprove of whoever I'm dating it's
super important for me I don't want her
to disapprove too much where she'll
never talk to me again but I want her to
disapprove just enough where she's like
I'm not gonna come to the wedding and
she still comes last-minute like if my
mom is not happy I'm like okay I'm on
the right track
mom just call me a [ __ ] yeah that means
you're perfect it can't be too bad like
if I was to start dating a semi and no
offense of smart my mom's it's like
sometimes I'm exposed to one more with 2
1 yeah ok honest to say my mom doesn't
approve of laughing it's not she means
well just they don't want to say what
you just said it listen I was racing ok
yes
well here's the thing like my mom god
bless her heart she never wanted me to
marry a white girl because mashed
potatoes right she's like they can't
cook mashed potatoes and I can't argue
with that you always the same my mom
doesn't approve I so I'm gonna tell you
two stories ok the first story my mom
wanted me to go to university and get
doctor right she want me to do the
engineering thing all that [ __ ] babe and
we come from a Muslim family so when I
joined the military at the height of the
9/11 business she kicked her ass out the
house well I mean I moved up boot camp
you live away so but I couldn't go back
anyways kicks away I come back home four
years later we get along we start
talking we're good
yeah I get along - uh if you don't come
back and pay my goddamn mortgage I
probably talk to you again I probably
would whoa maybe you did what yeah your
script
feels great shut up I love you so much
people said how will you do the kind
thing what I really just wanted was some
leverage and some power exactly James
the dynamic property look at you slippin
like yeah yeah get up this my seat now
[ __ ] this my and you know ask my food
too [ __ ] that is crazy
why cuz this is my house what you paying
stuff for your immigrant mother like you
start talking to her the same way white
people talk to their parents no I mean
what about people that Morgan she looked
at me like oh this piece of [ __ ] I
created is actually worth a damn maybe I
can get a free trip to Cancun out of
this [ __ ] I went to this [ __ ]
house and I saw his mom and his mom
didn't say [ __ ] bout me listen I'm not
the kind of dude I look like and your
mom would be like oh what's a nice
gentleman so when I step what went on
behind ABBA and I'm like you just closed
this you know it's gibberish and [ __ ]
and I just said number it's called my
language [ __ ] if you don't want
to if you want to call Crayola slang you
ain't gonna call my language some
[ __ ] gibberish can you I'm in
the middle of my act out can you [ __ ]
please just [ __ ] stand there and
salsa gibberish alright so jibber jabber
Zimmer [ __ ] temper yeah but yeah but
that is the most in approach oh you're
[ __ ] up my act out so you are white a
bit you are white this was not looking
flat this video what if you were money
yeah boy that's what you went on TV I
went the Haitians are speaking their
gibberish whatever my tip now you
should've did that you should have did
that team on the web anyways I'm getting
away with it privilege okay
zippers amber yabba-dabba-doo and I step
out like that
sneaky said yabba-dabba-doo
[ __ ] Flintstones naked don't
line up saying some racist [ __ ]
sometimes feels low-key fun like I talk
like a racist why do like [ __ ] hey so
yeah you walk up my mom's there next to
me oh it's that was friend he must have
a lot of money too I've never seen
please we listen appropriate for thought
it's great and also diverse know the
comments was preached cross the line was
he being a little piece of course now
holding my language Jewish this being
racist sometimes feel good for you guys
cuz it feels great for me I just did it
I just did it because it was you I
wouldn't go you will you wouldn't say
Java dabba-doo as a horse not of course
not you know I'm not like that so you
feel comfortable by insulting my culture
and my heritage no it's just you when
you see that bottom lip sample
alright that's it for today's video hope
you guys liked that if you guys want to
follow us we got a Facebook we got
Instagram we even got a patreon page so
if you guys want to give us a little bit
of some and then we give you know you
know I'm saying no okay and then we also
have some t-shirts would you start
merchandising so if you want a [ __ ]
shirt those are available check out the
links below cuz we're gonna have a whole
kinds of merchandise that we won't be
sound to guys because we know you guys
want to be about that Apple and peach
you already know what it is is there
anything else oh and we got our show
June 4th
right that's when we cool art gang be
there June 29th cookout here in Montreal
less busy